[Music]
jaren
is with us in fort worth texas hi jaren
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave hey ken how are y'all great man
how can we help
so i've got a situation so i've got
a 20 year old f-150 i've had since
i graduated high school and
i'm in baby step 2 and
i'm spending on average probably
five to six hundred a month and just
keeping this truck
continuing to go on and i'm sure you
about got it broke in do you
i got it broke in i just replaced the
tires put a new battery in it
not that i'm not mechanically inclined
it's i don't mind working on the truck i
kind of see it as a
halftime hobby sounds like
[Laughter]
but as much as i'm spending on a truck
at five to six hundred a month it's it's
hard for me and i know
how you feel about purchasing a new car
and i've been looking at used cars
and i'm i'm trying to see what's a good
point
to what would be a good used car for me
to get into
i know what i need to get into but i'm
i'm thinking that i'm probably going to
need to be
right around 22 000. good lord get into
a new car
you're driving a fifteen hundred dollar
truck and you're going up to twenty two
thousand
well it's twenty years old i know you're
drunk
but what justifies a move from fifteen
hundred to twenty two thousand
well reliability you've got to be
kidding me
you're probably right i am kidding you
yeah
so uh yeah you got you got you you're
really pissed
you are really pissed off about this
truck breaking and you
have got truck fever now yeah
yeah that's probably the best way to put
it i don't blame you
uh but i don't think we're gonna uh i
don't think the way you punish the truck
is um by getting one and making yourself
bankrupt
so okay so what do you make a year what
do you make of here
so i'm a self-employed contractor yeah
so
my my my my
growth or my net is between 20 to 50.
i've got 72 000 in the bank
i've got i'm finishing paying off i'm on
baby step two
uh i'm about to finish paying off this
eight thousand dollar loan here towards
the end of the month
uh i've got sixty thousand dollars in
retirement
so you have no doubt accepted your only
debt is eight thousand dollars and you
have seventy two thousand dollars in the
bank
right okay well let's slow down a minute
because baby step two the way that works
ken
is you take all the money that you don't
have in retirement and you pay off your
debts
so we're not gonna wait till the end of
the month you write the eight thousand
dollar check when you hang up
okay now you're debt-free now you're
debt-free
you're on baby step three and we need an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
sounds like fifteen thousand will cover
for that and so we're gonna move up
of the same 22 000 already in in a
separate account
okay on top of the 72. yes
okay so you gotta now now i understand a
little bit more where the truck favors
coming from okay
now we're down to you have your
emergency fund funded and your debt free
okay now we talk about paying cash for a
truck
and here's the guideline two guidelines
well one of them has to do being out of
debt so it doesn't apply because you're
out of debt we just
took care of that a minute ago and then
the next one
is that unless you have a net worth
in excess of a million dollars and what
you described to me doesn't
indicate that uh you don't buy brand new
you buy used
and you don't want to buy a anything
with motors
all the things you own with motors and
wheels don't need to add up to
more than half your annual income so
what did you pay taxes on
income wise in 2019
in 2019 i
only made 25 000.
what will you make this year uh this
year i'm on track to make over 137
000. that's all the money in the bank
okay so what do you think your average
income is going to be for the next five
years
my average income for the last the next
five years
the next five years i would like it for
it to be between 75 to 100 000.
okay so you can buy 22 000 our truck
then
i will recant you don't hear that very
often but i just backed up well to be
fair to you you didn't know that there
were 75
i didn't know there's 75 thousand
dollars laying in the bank either he's
got 64 left over
after he pays off the 8 000 yeah plus a
nice emergency yeah but i wouldn't buy a
new truck
no i'd buy a one-year-old one or
two-year-old and let someone else take
the butt kicking on the depreciation
and uh but but um i just reacted to 1500
to going to 22 000 but
yeah you you've got no you got your
value out of that first one
and uh i would as long as here's the
trick okay
the the we all all of us and and
you're in the construction business i
grew up in the real estate business uh
we have a tendency to rationalize
purchases
of things with motors and you have to be
careful with that and i thought that's
what you were doing
okay uh you don't have a history of
doing that but i thought that's what you
were doing
and you were a little bit because before
i found you yeah you would have i mean i
because
and if you don't look up you've got a
because everything that has motors and
wheels goes down
in value and you can't get rich putting
all your money in stuff that goes down
in value it's kind of a basic math thing
right and so that's where the ratio
comes to limit
your purchases of things with motors and
wheels total to be
less than half your annual income
and so you know what is your ending
because you just
they go down in value if it's got a
motor on it or wheels on it it goes down
in value and so
it's okay to buy those things i've got a
bunch of cars and boats and crap
but they all total up to considerably
less than half my annual income
and it's not prohibiting me then from
building wealth and that's the principle
that you're doing
in your case now that i got a better
picture i think he's okay to buy a truck
what do you think i think so too the
only guy i challenge him with is he's
doing very well i mean this is a young
man
who got his baby steps out of order but
he's gonna pay off the eight grand right
now and now he's in really good shape
he's
he's on you know baby step four and he's
and it kid's already doing that he's
already doing baby step four essentially
looks like with his retirement
here's the only thing i challenge him
with i i wanted to know why he felt like
he needed the truck
and so if he says well can i haul a
bunch of tools because the construction
nature
you know i'd look into something my
father-in-law has done very successful
uh he's got about a ten thousand dollar
suv and he's got a very nice trailer
that keeps its value because he carries
all of the tools in the trailer so if he
self
so now the value stays the same because
the trailer is something that is
a piece of equipment that will haul a
truck on a construction site
it's one thing yeah beat up that's it so
i don't know does he
brand new silverado going through a mud
puddle is a is a chevy commercial
yeah out here in the real world some
daryl and his other brother daryl buck
back a bobcat up into it you know or
throw a concrete block in the back of it
that's what we're having out here in the
real world